Tiffany huh
worried for urgent canvas but your child
cancer digital here how long you're
gonna do though about 16 years
yeah children yeah
no no three I don't know how I'll make
sure youngest boys are up Deborah
they're adopting the same families that
I had one like five years ago one like
seven years ago so you do the math and
then I have a 14 year old I guess you
know I'm 10 year old and twenty three
twenty two year old and a 17 year old
yeah but not my too much boys I know
well my kids are right about my M well
actually the two boys I don't know where
they aren't but they ended up in this
they got my god when I had him before so
um my kids are here my parents adopted
yeah then you talked a lot of states cuz
he took Baghdad drugs doing so my
parents ended up with my kids except for
the last two boys they didn't they are
they were already raising my daughter
she just graduated college
years ago that beautiful chica anyways
um how many years ago was that my
boyfriend and me without a fight cuz I
came home and there was a girl in the
tent and anyway so he was suffocating me
and I couldn't breathe so I was yanking
on his balls of his tick pinching at me
start punching this young
and the jaw several times really hard
my face was out here like knocked out my
tooth and then another one was like half
knocked down half named so I ripped it
out that tooth right here I was like
that long Wow
anyways and then um like it's time to go
buy one tooth to fall out and another
tooth fall out
I mean I had like seven pulled out lies
and jail you know up in the back and
stuff but all this right here Scott you
know important [ __ ] I can't count those
offer stupid [ __ ] only as serious time
resumed I went to the feds when I went
to the feds I did time brought out by
lady went back in and served my time and
I'm always going in for not Redemption
you know Lenny tickets end up into it
warrant and I it was for possession with
intent to distribute
what is your drug of choice heroin
unfortunately liberation you started
doing drugs yeah
13
so team seven started really using my
6:17 cocaine the first time I ever tried
any is out you mean nine drink the first
beer it J my first beer I think those
nineteen you want to see it raw
no it's just that I [ __ ] it's just
they I had abscesses like you see these
dots right here I had the same thing in
my arm and swelling up and so I put hot
water on it and it all bra all the pus
through the head and then I was able to
Lancet myself because my doctor which
was gonna drain it she make an artery so
she had to stop the put staples in there
she wanted to take me to the hospital
and torrents but I was like no so so
it's I drained it myself if I would have
known what I did know can you translate
soon wow it's really don't bug me about
hearing like this one right here that's
an abscess from muscling that I am I did
cut it open a little bit so she should
get the rest out I'm not that brave to
cut myself and it's not like big enough
to where powerful enough to where it
would like break a hole in your skin
Mabel not anymore well this thing not
like it was I don't even know I had it
until the other day I was poking on it
so I was like okay so I took an eel pup
and just drained it and yeah it's
already coming to a head
I'm sure put heat on I'm wiring with a
pipe up not really but I won't turn down
but I probably will too
depends on who it is why you want to
date I get massages - not just that
ya know I wish I could run my own back
[Music]
how am i teased in my own place
[Music]
and hopefully when my boyfriend if he
was just like find his mind but I know
that it won't be true but does not beat
up anymore
and off this [ __ ] it's always by that
you crystal meth just pucks him up like
that
I'm starting to kill himself the other
day
[Music]
I wanted to take me with him to the
Compton but I've already been to his
people's house you know and he calls my
kids hidden me caught and his kids he
says they're mine and no our
grandchildren [ __ ] and I've met the
family you date I'll say he loves you
and stuff I'm like he's really a
god-fearing you know Christian stuff but
he's really cruel to me blame stuff on
me everything everything like I must
start going dating him after I did that
photographer photographer with you
that's right
and it was like about two years which is
a relationship teeth got knocked out
so the Heron here yeah
on purpose yeah could my cat got ran
over and killed when I was in jail and I
was devastated plenty of pandas oh my
parent when I was dumb my mom gave me up
for adoption
me and my brother yell and she chose the
Mexican over us it's [ __ ] and he told
her three weeks after she signed private
adoption papers that she might think
that's a little bastard instead she
never see us again
what a creep huh he wanted her to marry
him New Mexican they had three kids I'm
sorry two kids no the three kids three
kids I'm the best amigo
me and my brother ended up in my adopted
family that was okay but mother died
from cancer and man was a trash man he
worked for the trash can be and he ended
up marrying remarrying the psycho [ __ ]
that was abused as molesting us and
ended up killing him in station as the
suicide all for his life-insurance money
it was horrible you got molested and
abused she was just for show anyway I
really got to get back to my laundry
thank you yeah I don't want to rush it
though because you're paying me 20 bucks
so if there's anything more well sure I
don't know I mean I'm I can wait all
right thank you what a good seeing you
again
Nessa see you here was your name ma Mike
this is your brain this is your brain on
drugs equations and I got another one on
the other say that you did another one
that says that's open no it's not no
easy okay she opened it landscape yes
now let me show you
plants train I'm not taking them dunning
but enough but I'm pretty sure that
somebody that it busted when it was in
spite being slapped because it just like
started late like just going down all of
a sudden right and I think there was
some leakage a little bit so that's
probably possible huh absolutely Cyrus
you got [ __ ] [ __ ] like Street
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on with you
don't yeah but there's a look like a
spot where it could have been open cuz I
want to so badly a draw without your ass
is not nearly as bad as your shoulder
oh wait wait wait wait wait yeah